[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett it's time for another conversation
with someone interesting from the
internet or someone's to be specific
that's Pomplamoose a california-based
musical duo consisting of real-life
couple jack conte and nataly dawn okay
now if you are a fan of music and/or you
are so am i or if you like getting
inside the brains of musicians then this
ear biscuit is for you I like to do that
sorry about this one I almost went to
medical school to operate exclusively on
the brains of musicians because they had
a lot of money no just because I found
their brains interesting and I wanted to
press on it during surgery so they would
make different notes and I could play
music through their birth through their
brains during surgery I guess all
musicians don't have a lot of it does it
does get pretty deep in this
conversation with Papa moose it doesn't
get that deep though there is no brain
pressing that happens now here's the
thing we have been fans of Pomplamoose
since way back I'm talking like mm Oh 8
pages of the internet mm oh eight so
when we reach into them at playlist live
in Orlando you know it was the first
time we met him and we were ready to
record some ear biscuits at playlist and
so they were the first one and this
wasn't planned I gotta say that we that
we tried to work out a few interviews at
playlist ahead of time but we just saw
Jack and Natalie in a in the suite and
what was it the hospitality hospitality
suite they were enjoying some of the
hospitality we said we got to talk to
Papa moose huge fans and we got to talk
to them on ear biscuits and an hour
after meeting them we brought him up to
her hotel room and had this conversation
and I gotta say I don't know if we were
like fanboying but there was about what
fangirling beyond fanboying there was
some sort of connection then I felt like
we made so in listening this ear biscuit
I think you can pick up on a friendship
blossoming with Papa moose so if you
don't know them I'm I'm glad you get to
know them along with us in this ear
biscuit they gained attention through
their incredibly creative covers of
popular songs and
we're gonna play a snippet of one here
yeah this is uh I think their most
popular video to date this is their
cover of Beyonce's single ladies
[Music]
okay so that was the first cover I think
but they went on to do a lot of other
amazing covers including Michael
Jackson's beat it
[Music]
okay I think you can tell by listen to
that this is no ordinary cover this is
not just trying to make a song that
sounds exactly like the original they
bring a totally unique musical approach
to all their covers but in addition to
that they do something that we can't
display in audio form and that is the
visual approach what they call video
songs we get into exactly what that is
and we also uncover what I guess I would
call a chip on their shoulder
surrounding the fact that they built
their brand on covers when they are
legitimate artists who have original
songs which they want to get out there
incredible original songs let's play a
snippet of one can you introduce it like
a radio DJ yeah next up we've got an
original from Pomplamoose band out of
California if you think you need some
lovin
shrink it raise another sink well go if
you think you need a fix to put me in
the mix just
[Music]
and there's more where that came from
next up we've got also from Papa Moe's
Hail Mary
[Music]
[Music]
I I don't see any reason why we just
don't get into this conversation I hope
you're as excited as we are we also talk
about their relationship why they
disappeared from YouTube for a while and
then while their what their plans are
for coming back stronger I was
especially intrigued linked with how
they balance their romantic life with
their musical relationship it's really
quite an eye-opening thing here it is
our ear biscuit with Jack and Natalie of
Papua moose owl
[Music]
so this is something that you're that
you're encountering at this point though
is a lots of messages coming in you read
some of them you don't
what about fan mail it all comes to one
spot which I know we need to we need to
designate split off and have a separate
you have a p.o box we do have a peel box
yeah and you you read everything that
comes to the PIO box no we don't check
the peel box that's another problem so
the main problem is we live in two
different places right now I just
realized we haven't checked her mail
since Courtney yeah it's been like
months we all shut it down and
everything yeah the USPS right it's
actually not with it's not a p.o box
it's a it's a physical address through
UPS so somebody's house no it's an it's
an actual box but you get a physical
address it's not a p.o box it's a you it
costs more but it still goes to because
some people don't deliver to peal boxes
however okay as interesting as the mail
situation is right now no we live
together we live together if you're
living in two different place yes
because you know yeah I'm doing the solo
career you're asking if they're a couple
I know that they're a couple we Natalie
and I live together in two different
places sometimes we live where we record
in just north of Petaluma in Sonoma
County we live there together we that's
where our studio is and then the other
half the time we live at the patreon
office in San Francisco yeah so it's we
are splitting
and right now your your split up from
each other no we live together that's
always that's what I asked every night
we spend together and every day a lot of
the nights I understand they're a couple
they live together but there's two
different places it's like they both
live at the same time it's pretty simple
even speaking the same time that's
pretty sweet
okay almost eight years going on the
ears together really what now you did
you was that like a something you kind
of had to the forefront right at the
beginning of your career you were like
we're a couple because I remember asking
like are they is this a couple and I no
I don't think so I think they just sing
to girlfriends I don't know a friend
yeah that was kind of you to not assume
that we were in a relationship because I
feel like a lot of people who they do
any sort of collaboration on YouTube
it's like they're in a relationship
right now and it's like and then if and
if you're not then everybody
disappointed and they're not gonna buy
your iTunes single or whatever yeah it's
like when I found out to the people from
once weren't really a couple how many
movies do you watch would you thought
they weren't actors acting I remember
thinking that too though I do know what
you're talking about it was so indeed it
was so and it was like had to be real
you thought it was found footage yeah
the whole movie one scenario documentary
you know how recording sea water doctor
first take sounds amazing
yeah go at it yeah the engineer looks up
from his magazines like wow these guys
are good and that's how it is in a
recording studio it's messing around you
know right now the projectors I want to
start with the the last two videos if
you guys put out are the are both the
projector music videos things yeah so I
want to pick your brain on that patent
did this and then go backwards have not
penned it you should I commented on the
Lord back to POC mashup one yeah yeah I
was just so excited I when I saw it I
was like this is
this is great this is amazing and I was
like okay it's already got two million
views and I was like no it it doesn't it
hadn't broken a million views yet so I
was like still hasn't this the least I
can do and so I was actually frustrated
for you guys being a long time fan with
both the longtime fans for that one in
particular to be so innovative in this
particular projector type way I was like
oh this is this is a this is another big
one so I was gonna do my little part and
comment but now you regret commenting
cuz it turns out it wasn't a big one but
you'd approach in a million views and
you did it you did a sequel you've done
another one
well I think's going you right what's
the thought process and kind of doing
the projectors yeah well so you know
first of all Papa moose is like getting
back into the swing of it after not
being a channel for like two years yeah
and you know we took some time to like
pursue solo projects and Pablos was like
this thing that we did for fun and then
it became the most successful thing that
either one of us were involved with and
then it felt like a burden because we
felt like we had to keep it going and it
was it stopped being fun and at a point
the burden of artistry it was it got to
be a point it got to be a we need to
take this to the next level and we need
to work with a manager and we needed to
make a hit song and right and it was
just like yeah and then we just drove
we got sick and tired and depressed and
we just took a break from it because it
was too it's too much we sucked
ourselves out so we're just getting back
into it now and so that's why I sort of
don't feel bad it's like okay there's
like two videos and we'll keep doing
more and you know we'll make a bunch and
maybe and maybe as we make more you know
they feed on each other like the more
you release the better the previous ones
do and so as we release more that you
know those those are the ones are gonna
I'm sure continue to do better so was
the did the projector idea kind of light
a spark to reinvigorate your channel or
did you have a spark that this was the
first application of it well we've been
working on recording we we have probably
about eight songs right now that we have
released like the video as well no
videos but just music so we deciding to
get back into Pomplamoose was a hurdle
and of itself because we we wanted
Pomplamoose to be fun again and and
there are so many things that get in the
way of something being fun so we were
trying not to plan too far ahead to just
make it about the music and so we went
back in we recorded these several songs
for the last few months and then decided
that it was time to start putting stuff
out and the best way to put stuff out
when you've been out of the loop for a
while is to buy a bunch of projectors
buy a bunch of project oK you've been
watching well you kind of let you finish
cover is like you know it's that's
that's how you write that's cuz
otherwise people aren't going to notice
that you put out an original so you
start by putting out covers and so we're
gonna slowly start putting out originals
with those covers in it but the
projector part of it how did that come
about
so that was an accent yeah so on my solo
channel I have been working with so EDM
is a very difficult thing to make to do
live I don't know what it stands for
electronic dance music really yeah
that's intuitive you're wondering if I'm
joking I was I was actually looking at
you like that's why I didn't know that
and if I if I know so it feels free to
not know it I mean I I've can make my
brain for something else that's amazing
that one doesn't seem like it would have
taken a much space not sure how you got
through 2013 we've had this discussion
I've explained it to him I don't believe
you it seemed too simple okay right yeah
okay so it's a difficult thing
electronic dance music is a difficult
thing to to do live right so how do you
bring it to YouTube how do you create a
live performance experience of
electronic dance music the thing is it
takes thousands of hours to craft those
sounds they can't be produced live I
mean I record a guitar and then I
manipulate the crap out of it until it
growls and screeches and grunge's and
has sub base and it's layered with other
things and there's a million and it's
impossible to show that like Papa Luis
would show video songs right like we
would do so so I you know I wanted to do
have some kind of video where the the
odd where the the visuals wasn't the
sound that was being made but rather it
was a visual representation of that
sound it made your brain go ah that's
the same thing so if it's a yo-yo
wobble bass then you see a line kind of
wobbling with the bass or you see
flashes of lights and boxes at certain
times so that there was some kind of
synesthetic you know correlation between
the sound and the video so I was
experimenting with projectors and
lighting things and one time I held up
my hand because I was going to I was
using a projector and I went to hold up
my hand to grab something and my face
got projected on my palm you know and I
was like woah and I moved my hand face
there was my face and I did this know
that and and it was it was just cool to
see the the rest of the image I behind
my why were you projecting your face in
the first place I was rejecting my face
because I was projecting myself onto a
screen on I built a screen and I was
playing a launch pad in front of the
screen and so I was protecting my face
onto the screen and I went to grab the
launch pad and boom there's my face in
my head I thought wow that's cool to see
multiple dimensions with one projector
and then I held up a white card and my
face popped and was really clear now and
then I put up a couple cards and just
just literally just white car it's like
note cards and put them up at various
depths and then dragged around images in
Final Cut Pro until they were on the
cards that's a good feeling right when
you discover something like wow it was
so cool looking it was so cool just to
you know to move around and see these
things in three dimensions and then it
was just kind of snowballed from there
it's like one video after the next just
okay now more techniques more techniques
more I do see you were doing them on
your your personal channel yes a
projector yeah okay I haven't seen you
you gotta check those out yeah those
have over a million views really yeah
really
okay and what your personal channel is
uh is is just as my stuff just jack
conte music yeah my solo stuff got it
yeah it's more like whoa angry like EDM
like yeah kind of stuff hardcore like
electro okay so that was working on your
channel so you brought it back over to
go with this mashup that you guys yeah
the poplu moves channel to reinvigorate
it yeah okay so it's kind of so it's
kind of a proven thing that it's not
it's not just two of them there's a lot
of them on your channel that have gone
viral
yeah okay are you guys kind of oh I mean
kind of own that concept as far as I can
tell I have I don't know if anybody's
emulated it but I definitely one of the
things we struggle with is thinking
about innovating and doing things that
people haven't done before and I think
it was much easier to do that in o8 r o9
you know but now you're like oh that's
been done that's been done is it's kind
of rare to find something that's that
innovative that cool works that well for
ya it works yeah it's like oh you surely
someone has done this before
right but you know they have it and it's
just it's amazing right there is
projection mapping like people do
projection mapping but it uses a lot of
math and special software I haven't seen
people like just drag [ __ ] around and
not like use mapping software to make it
perfect I think what's cool about the
you know the projection videos that
we've done is that they're they look
kind of bad does that make sense like it
looked mannish yeah you can tell that
it's there's there's no fancy software
or fancy know-how it's just it's just
dragging stuff around and Final Cut I
mean it you can see how it's made it's
still got that very Internet II quality
to it which arm yeah and you're actually
drawing attention to how you do the
technique so that people can appreciate
it more right exactly and I mean if we
shift over to the video songs I mean you
guys certainly innovated on that front
as well in terms of coming up with that
which there were rules involved in
making a video song so take take me back
through though
or and let take me back through the
concept of where you came up with that
do you guys divide is this a
collaborative part of it do you guys
work on the music together and then one
of you is geeking out more about how we
transfer this into a video how does that
work and where did the video song idea
come from
it was Jack's idea I could talk about it
but it was Jack's idea is is that cut is
is that kind of a division between you
two that yeah you two you're taking more
though okay this is this is how we're
gonna do this music video geeking out on
that kind of thing is that more your
thing so I have a film-like background
so I mean I do but Natalie's and she
edited all the video songs she did all
the really okay yeah on almost every
single one of them so but not for the
projection videos I haven't done I
haven't edited those but I did at it
almost all the the old Pomplamoose
videos okay yeah so you came up with the
split screen the video concept a video
song concept yeah so with so subject to
certain rules yeah okay so so are you
guys familiar with the dogma shoot oh I
camera don't remember the numbers there
is a group of four or filmmakers in the
60s who got sick of Hollywood
productions okay and and they came up
with a set of rules that you have to
shoot on location you have to use direct
sound
you can't overdub and they just wanted
something that was more real they just
wanted something that was more organic
and more like life and less like fake
art and I'm not sure I necessarily agree
with that but I like the idea of coming
up with rules and constraints and
parameters you know help you be creative
and and for us the trouble was okay you
know here's our stuff on MySpace and it
gets three plays a day this is 2007
right so we're like nothing's happening
on MySpace and we're desperately trying
to you know make music for a living and
and we have all these songs we needs to
figure out a way to convert it somebody
sends me
linked to a guy who on YouTube who's got
350,000 hits and he's sitting in front
of a webcam playing guitar and it's like
what you know he's got an OK voice it's
not great ok guitar not great it's like
why are we putting our songs in my space
we need to putting our songs on YouTube
so how do we convert music to video
where people are right and so for me the
video song was like a function it was
like an equation that converted music to
video and this sounds pity I don't mean
to sound when I say this way but it
required not very much creativity to do
it wasn't it wasn't it didn't take
creative juice to make each video we
just would go in the studio and make the
audio and once the audio was made the
video kind of followed Natalie did an
amazing job editing but it wasn't that
we had to come up with a creative
concept for every single music video
because you but you because he had rules
yeah and what were the rules the rules
were no so no lip-synching for
instruments or voice if you see it in
the video that's the take that you're
actually hearing hmm so when you see
Natalie singing those the takes that we
used in the audio and the second rule is
no hidden sounds no hidden sounds so so
if you hear something in your earphones
got a same point you you saw it in the
video so there's not every time it
occurred but it's somehow it's something
you weren't you deme you showed people
what was happening our words we're not
hiding stuff from you like you get to
see how the music is actually happening
as it's actually recorded because I can
tell you when Beyonce records she
doesn't do it in heels and full makeup
she's in that sound booth a freaking
sweater you know write it with a bottle
of water next her and she probably looks
like crap right I mean was as much like
crap as be on this bouncy can exactly so
she looks at me are you saying I look
like crap
answer the question okay no fair
question no you do not look like crap
you always look amazing amazing no no
you guys can't run ads over this I just
sang Bruno Mars oh this song we're good
we won't tell her
no actually Bruno's the guy who runs ads
over this for us okay he's got he's our
ad guy side job
his name's Bruno Mars was the was this
yeah I like the sort of the anti feeling
of the philosophy because there's so
much that is faked on the internet and
they're in even lip-synching videos at
the time that you guys were really
breaking out I mean lip-synching videos
we're still a big thing on YouTube was
there a part of this it's like oh this
is a great opportunity I see that
YouTube is a great platform but we want
to do it differently then it's being
done was that really is it was that sort
of the philosophical approach definitely
there there's some of that and then
there's also just some of the feeling
that I enjoy when I see art is I can do
that as it was I'll never be able to do
that right like when I listen to a band
who's just cloaked behind marketing and
and sort of unattainable veils I feel
like I'll never that's something I'll
never be able to achieve they're perfect
they're on a cloud making perfection and
letting the world listen to it right and
I'll never be a part of that mm-hmm and
I don't want people to feel like that
when they listen to our art I want them
to feel like wow I could do that
I feel like that's a more inspiring
feeling that's a feeling that I
appreciate when I see art that I like is
a feeling of empowerment as opposed to
belittlement I remember the first time
that I heard Nirvana it was actually
seeing the the music video for smells
like teen spirit right and I remember my
reaction was I can do that if there's
something about the way that it was
presented and the way that it sounded
was very the first time that I
understood music is something that I
could emulate now I actually couldn't
but I was under the illusion that I
could and I think that was at least
remote or something that was exciting
that kind of drew me in I also think I
can do what you guys can do
no I cuz I can safely say that I don't
think that anything that you've ever
seen in one of our videos is what you're
hearing I can safely say that we haven't
followed that philosophy but because I'm
just thinking about how many how much
footage you got to deal with are you
guys what the number of takes that we
owe you to sing something right yeah it
would just be way too much footage in
too much time it's like I mean it's
frustrating enough for us to just go
through the audio takes alone to add I
don't want to see myself struggling to
hit that no yeah no well so I'm just
wondering how you guys kind of keep it
so fun and just light and cuz I know
behind the scenes and this is this is
like a challenge for us like I know
there's contracts and like negotiation
business and lots of business and you
know growing the channel and right and
and okay more content and like right
there's all those pressures and and then
yet when you tune in it's funny and
silly and how the F do you do that well
it's funny because you guys I think kind
of remind me of Julian Smith you know
he's youtuber friend of ours who makes
him incredible yeah he's he's make some
incredible YouTube videos but he is how
many sketches that look amazing he's
very much a filmmaker and he's very
methodical he's I would say a
perfectionist incredible artist so that
everything that he does is is great and
that's how I see what you guys do it
comes from an artistic conviction that
if there's not something struck within
him that I hear you kind of articulate
that there's a chord within your you as
an artist that has to be struck for you
to continue to create right like we
talked to him on your biscuits and one
of the things he said was that there was
a time when he kind of like last year he
sort of stopped making videos because he
felt like he was just like he didn't
have anything great to do on YouTube
anymore and now he's kind of back but he
took this break and we were talking
about however saying is we don't have
that chord know I guess what I'm saying
I feel like we're so practical not that
we I mean I would say are we artists do
we create that yes we we technically do
that but we're so practical that we've
kind of created this like this is a this
is what we do Monday through Friday we
come into our studio we are gonna get
this this and this done I mean we have
engineering degrees both of us have an
engineering degree so we don't come from
a very informed artistic background I
think some of that there's just this
very practical approach the even that
means sometimes we get ready to record
our morning show good mythical morning
and we are not in a good mood but we're
like this show is needs to be a Bryce
button people's day so let's Center
ourselves and let's it's not that we're
acting but it's just like for this show
even if I'm worried about this thing for
this show I'm doing this we're gonna be
happy we're gonna make each other laugh
and that kind of thing yeah so I think
it's just it's just a very practical
approach that we just we're not artistic
enough I honestly I say we're not
artistic enough to get to the point
where we would ever come to the
conclusion like I I you know this
doesn't feel right so I'm gonna take a
break hmm
that's just well I mean you know we've
got a lot of we've got families and
there's a lot more at stake when there's
other people that's true so that's kind
of a trump card but we also try to do
other things at the same time that can
be in a new creative challenge like
doing your biscuits for us I'm not
acting in any way I'm legitimately
interested in you know who you guys are
where you're coming from what you've
created because I'm a fan so for me this
is kind of this is a creative outlet
whereas you know maybe 15% of the time
doing good mythical morning every single
weekday for us is something that we I
have to access something that I'm not
feeling at the time so there's you know
it's it's performing right but it's not
so it's creating in the moment but it's
not creating a whole album out of
obligation I I certainly don't think we
could do that and I wouldn't expect any
great artists to do that you know you
hear about people under contracts do I
got to give Columbia Records another
album like does that answer your
question
totally
we're not half the artists you are
that's why we're talking to you I'm big
to differ but well I want to find out
you know I we we don't have time to hear
each of your entire life story but I
want to find out the point in which your
lives intersected and maybe some things
that you think contributed to which we
can kind of get into this the mentality
that you have you know this this I would
say it's a it's a pure artistic
mentality that you bring to things that
you had adopt a formula to bring to your
your your work on YouTube and just as
musicians in general I want to kind of
find out what contributed to that yeah
so how did you guys meet yeah well we
were going to the same University and
which was freshman Stanford Stanford
I've heard of it
[Music]
so I was a freshman and Jack was a
senior we've got a four-year disc
discrepancy here that's actually three
because I was okay I was kind of read it
agreed when I moved to France a
different story um so he moved to France
to redo a grade so people wouldn't be
like oh look at her she's held back I'm
about of France to do that great again I
want to do this in French and see how
different it is they're great in France
so you okay so you went to you did
fifth grade in in America and you did
fifth grade again in France which was
better uh well France was less
comprehensible for me because I didn't
speak French so that was why
that was why I would I would um any
class I didn't understand first of all
nobody spoke English in the whole school
and I didn't speak French and it was a
little little country school where they
would ring the bell to start classes and
any time I couldn't understand what was
happening in the lesson they'd be like
Natalie why don't you go spend time with
the kindergarteners and learn how to
like write cursive and like play with
puppets and so that was my second fifth
year
was well hanging out with French
kindergarteners and then I learned
French and then everything was great
everything changed and then later on I
did you stay in France like your parents
yeah my parents were missionaries and so
I was I was in France and Belgium from
10 to 18 and then okay well
the formative years yes what flavor
missionary are we talking about here
Pentecostal evangelical okay
Pentecostal Angelica picante I was
trying to characterize it in a way that
was like positivity what flavor
Oh what flavor this surprising flavor
spice of life comes with it so then at
some point you decided and I would say
that Pentecostal I would call that the
spicy spicy you know reach out and bite
you but you'll be okay
if it's a snake you'll be okay your
parents were snake handling really good
place okay French snake handlers got it
so Stanford so then yes so then we met
there I was I was opening for his band
and he walked in and saw me playing the
bass and singing as like solo solo I
this is college so just picture me
playing a bass you didn't have a chance
and it was over yeah literally it was
like a it was kind of like smoky foggy
in there
Wow is this like tall beautiful girl on
stage with this huge bass and bass and
and just like so not a stand-up bass an
electric bass electric bass and yes yes
sorry yes it was an electric bass and I
would play chords on it literally like
we locked eyes and I literally like was
looking at her for like four seconds
just looking at me she says she doesn't
sing when she plays where her head is
tilted down she like looks she's looking
at me and I'll it was like one of those
things where like I tripped over stuff
and like and still I kept I contact and
then leaned over to my ex-boyfriend
right I didn't know what was the next
boyfriend and said he was like this was
a relationship that you had ended kisses
wow that's amazing
[Music]
[Laughter]
what were you singing I just you know
just to just a girl with the bass alone
singing boy Johnny Cash well no no no
okay
there were all things that I had written
I figured out when I was when I was
actually about eighteen that whenever I
was writing songs I was hearing
intertwining melodies and and so I asked
my parents if they would get me a bass
guitar because I wasn't really hearing
chords so much as melodies and so that I
would play sort of meandering melodies
and the so the vocal melody would sort
of cross with the base melody and do you
do it do you do this the same style and
your solo stuff now um no not not really
um but a bass is a really important way
of how Jack and I write together yeah we
basically Natalie will often write a
melody in a bassline and I just kind of
fill in the holes yeah really I wouldn't
put it that way I mean that's often one
way we
one way we write that I feel like a lot
of the time so what happens is you write
a really cool chord progression and have
an idea for a melody and say okay now
now now write a really cool bassline
right just write a bass line and then
you sort of alter the you alter what you
wrote to fit around the bass line right
so is this an argument right now I think
guys have our arguments you know how he
did do they get heat it quantify that we
never raise our voice our voices never
grow things right okay
never never raised voices never yell at
each other but we do make each other sad
sometimes as couples do right that's a
nice way to put it yeah yeah do you flee
each other's presence like I mean my
wife and I when we we've kind of fixed
it for the most part but early on in our
relationship we would have these
knock-down drag-out fights which would
mean she would run and like into the
garage and lock me out so like I
couldn't get to her anymore to have more
of an argument Wow I would be trying to
fix it and she would be trying to
process dang that's pretty that's always
intense she's like just go away let me
figure this out you guys don't do that
anymore
no we don't she doesn't sequester
herself we can't we it's not as heated
it's more right just let's just talk
this talk about it yeah we have we have
cycles of upsetting each other to things
that we've had to like sort of break
break the cycle when we get into an
argument like I would I'd say something
that would unintentionally upset Jack
and then he would get frustrated me and
then I would ask him why he was upset
and then he would say why he was upset
and I'd apologize and be like oh I
didn't mean to upset you and I hold
grudges and then he would take me along
you wouldn't get over it and then I
would get angry at him for still being
upset with me for something that I
didn't mean to upset him about and
especially after you apologized friend
she's totally in the right here I was
like very willing to admit that Natalie
is the better person here like
absolutely
it takes me a little while to forgive I
don't know what that is but I hold on to
it I just I have emotional inertia it
just takes a while to like to breathe
out of me right yeah so I just have to
give him the space and and not I have to
not get angry at him for still
processing everything but he's gotten a
lot better at like processing things
faster because of you because because
I'll do something really dickish and
you'll and then I'll realize how much of
a jerk I am and I'll say I'm sorry and
you'll say that's okay I know you love
me and then you're like happy and
chipper and talking about already
Rocking I'm like what the because I
would be like me are you for like a day
yeah okay so and all of this came out in
the in that that first meeting I assume
right yeah so the kisses taste like jazz
what happened next
we dated for a couple years and we we
didn't really collaborate on music
because that's kind of like the kiss of
death for a relationship we started by
collaborating on music and I didn't when
we broke up right and then we got back
together and we're like no more music
and together not separately we could do
music but we weren't collaborating on
and you were still at Stanford and you
had graduated yes and what were you
doing at the time uh I was doing a
couple things I started off right after
I graduate stuff as an SAT tutor mm-hm
not really proud of that then I started
working as doing background music for
for Google actually I did like I was a
in-house composer and and did like
directed videos and things for them for
their like in-house video production
department really yeah
and they offered because you had a
filmmaking yeah agreeing a film yeah
well I didn't have a degree in film a
degree in music okay I I was actually
going to go to film school after college
I got in I was ready to go MSC
fine school at the very last minute I
didn't go because I was in
hot band and i wanted to do music so I
not complement the other different band
I'd been and were you studying music
also no I was I wasn't planning on being
a musician I was I don't know what I was
planning on being but I was definitely
planning on doing something that made
money and where I could actually have an
income and and like a but you didn't
have a plan what was a major well I was
I was majoring in art and mastering in
French literature at the same time and
and don't don't really know what I was
planning on doing with that I think I
was just planning on getting two degrees
right and then doing something that was
not related to either yeah so so then
what you guys music broke up your
relationship was more important so you
did music separately it's kind of a
hobby you were kind of doing the the
music job thing but yeah and then Jack
started posting some of his stuff on
YouTube or myspace first I thought you
said but then YouTube when did you when
did you 2007 and at that point he he
thought that it would be really good for
me to have a youtube channel too so he
produced my first song for me but you
had made the decision just as a couple
we're not gonna collaborate on music
because that was devastating the first
time right right yeah and then what what
was it that made us start working on
music together I think it was the
response to that video yeah what was the
first video you're talking to owner on
her channel that with this song you
produced yeah we ended up posting it on
my channel okay because I had more
subscribers at the time and we wanted to
get people over to my channel yeah yeah
and and all my subscribers said like you
know Jack really liked your music man
but this is really good it's like no
offense jack but this is this is like we
like this and what what was you in it no
no I was I was in it playing he was
playing all of the ants
this video but Natalie but see what and
you were but you kind of saw it as I'm a
I'm like a producer and I'm playing some
instruments and yeah and I'm in the
video a little that's her video for her
things I just kind of did some
production on it right and it plays was
an original so this was one of my
originals this was it sort of at the end
of producing it though we felt we both
felt like it would be weird to call it a
nataly dawn song because I had messed it
up so much or not mess it up but made it
just something else there's a lot of
jack in it there was a lot of jack in it
yeah and and so so we we when we posted
it we didn't even have a band name
right no we didn't have a band name
until we wrote our first song together
right which happened I guess about a
month later you were in my my dorm room
and you were playing the guitar and I
just started singing over
I sang a melody over the guitar line
that he was playing and he said what's
that and I said I don't know I just sang
something and he was like I'll keep
going
and so then we wrote our first song
together and posted that very naturally
yes like alright let's have a meeting
are we going to collaborate it was just
like no what just keep playing that I
keep singing it and it kept doing better
than either of our solo projects I think
the way we rationalized it was that it
was it was a side project it wasn't
either of our remain focus then it
started really taking off and we weren't
super prepared for that what they might
were the mechanics of that like what
song or video really popped for pop
Lumos well and why did you call it
Pomplamoose by the way because because
we didn't care we if we would have cared
no it's true I mean a friend of mine got
back from France and we were talking
about learning French and she told me
that the funniest French word that she'd
learned while she was there was
Pomplamoose which means great fruit
and I thought oh yeah that is a really
weird word and then the next day Jack
and I were like yeah let's I guess we
should have a band name what do you
think about Pomplamoose oh yeah that's
good I guess there were no other
suggestions for abandon it was there was
not a single other suggestion so we just
went with Pomplamoose I got the URL well
it's I mean it's a good band I like
fabulous I'm totally cool with it but it
has an animal in it before all the
hipster bands had animal names in their
band I'm happy with the name too but it
was an accident in it it was totally an
afterthought and what popped single
ladies single ladies yes that was the
first one okay that was it yeah we we
had 500,000 views overnight in 2009 when
that was a lot of views Yeah right
we went from 10,000 to 50,000
subscribers in months yeah couple and
was that you know a lot of people that
we we talked to we get the impression
that they sort of were just kind of
studying YouTube and kind of figuring
out what would work and they're like oh
well if we do this this is gonna like
what was the thought process behind
saying we're gonna do this we're gonna
cover single ladies yeah we produce a
record for an incredible singer
songwriter that I love named Julia Nunes
and and I was one day into youtube I
just typed the Beatles and her video
popped up before any Beatles videos and
I was like what yeah what is happening
here and you already knew her I did know
her you're like that's Julia is the
Beatles result yeah and and that's when
I started learning about SEO and started
thinking about covering songs and again
this like people were covering songs
back then but not like people are
covering songs now I mean now like
people just go through the iTunes top
ten and they just crank him out like
week after week in 2009 people were not
doing that like cover songs was not a
method like nobody was doing that there
were some people who were covering pop
songs but they weren't like iTunes top
ten it was like what songs do I like oh
yeah
like Mariah Carey song right and this
old bela Fleck song and oh here's a new
one and I like the one that just came
out on the radio I'll do that one and
then you know so so it wasn't scaliness
pandering to get views and now it very
much is and you know I guess I feel bad
about that we are partaking in that yeah
I don't know ah see I feel like it's so
important to be innovative and try
something different and yet the system
is optimized for SEO right it's like we
all know how the algorithms work yeah
and ignoring it is honestly just
shooting yourself in the foot like it
really is I so it I'm not I haven't
figured out a way around it yet I would
love to but yeah looks like but you
found a way I mean not only would the
fact the video format of the video song
being this innovative creative
expression but you found a way to do a
cover of Beyonce or Michael Jackson or
whoever the case may be that is very
much uniquely your voices your the the
pop lamu sound that I think that you
know I mean I guess that was calculated
but I mean that maybe that's the
redemptive aspect of it for you guys
from an artists perspective
yeah we don't take a song and and not
you know think about how to
reharmonization it and and present it in
a different size exactly
we're usually take one element of the
song and then ditch everything else
right so we'll like take just the melody
or just a chorus sometimes or we'll
combine pieces of songs that we like the
course of this with the verse of that
because they would work nicely together
or the chords of this song with the
verse melody of that's right so yeah we
usually just like take something and
then we strip everything else away and I
guess that makes it feel a little bit
more creative yeah I tell ya I mean I
definitely when you talk about it I see
that just the way we talked about that
the pure artistic approach did that pure
artists in each one of you kind of has
this like hesitancy to I
well wish we didn't have to do a cover
song I wish we could just do the
original things but at the same time
like you feel like you're apologizing
almost yeah even here but in in and I
feel like to kind of go back to the
differences like the way that we think
about it I think there is there is we
definitely talk about how we want to be
innovative we don't we don't want to do
something that somebody else has done
but we definitely sit around anything
like if you want to you want to stay in
this YouTube thing you have to look at
those patterns and you have to adapt and
you have to some people just flat-out
just game the system
game it and we don't want to do this
arms race but you have to take into
account the reality and but the cool
thing about what you guys do is you're
like man that was so there was something
so innovative about that cover that
wasn't just a typical cover it it
immediately draws you into the band and
the originals you know it kind of moves
you into that experience like oh what
happened what else are these guys done
because I can tell that they can write
songs just because you know I can tell
it there's something else going on here
this isn't just somebody who has a
producer good cover a good voice yeah
thank you and I would go beyond that
it's like what I think we're trying to
convince you guys not to be great
I would go step further and say that I
mean you guys if it wasn't for what you
did I mean you look at the walk off the
earth of the YouTube space now I think
them being some of the you know the
foremost most successful in that way of
okay we're taking this cover but we're
doing it in this extremely creative
expression of it
you know I haven't talked to them about
you guys but I have to assume that they
wouldn't they wouldn't be here if it
wasn't for you guys innovating in that
way you know I think that it's inspired
people to be creative and there may be
some gaming the system to it or working
within the system but also doing that
subject to your own yeah you know your
own convictions so to speak I think it's
funny how how many
sort of versions of the of the metaphor
there really are four for the
combination of gaming and true artistic
creativity just in even in music when
Natalie and I write music we think of a
combination of tension and release right
so like chords that sound nice and
chords that sound a little like they're
not settled yet and then they settle and
that's nice and like having a balance of
in and out and tension and release and
gaming the system and not gaming the
system and you know being creative and
following the algorithm right you kind
of have to apply in and out so you have
every aspect of your business in your in
your creativity because if you just if
you're if you are a hundred percent pure
artists about it and you don't do any
you don't at least acknowledge the
system then you write beautiful songs
that nobody ever hears yeah and that's
like one thing that we're figuring out
trying to figure out how to cope with is
like okay we feel like a little bit
ashamed but at the same time we you know
we want people to hear our music because
we're proud of it mm-hmm
you know and so so we feel like we owe
it to ourselves to to take advantage of
the things that we know how to do hey
has anyone ever confronted you you know
you seem to have this defensive stance
but have you heard that from anybody
totally really yeah like besides the
comments because I mean like in
face-to-face it's mostly when we get
lumped into the category of bands on
YouTube oh yeah bands do great covering
songs in YouTube but nobody can actually
sell originals right nobody like none of
them are actually songwriters they're
just car bands you know and then the
listeners yeah like that whole media
thing that yeah you know and the truth
is like our original songs have just as
many or more hits as some of our covers
- um it's not you know it's just that
you know people know us for the covers
and that's our own fault right we we
made the covers it was that part of the
you call it a burnout like that you guys
that you guys experienced and when was
that and what led to it was it was part
of it like feeling like hamsters in a
wheel if you want to do this you have to
play this game and what led to the
burnout it's really hard to just pick
out the juiciest most personal aspect of
it and tell us about that juiciest most
personal aspect of it what would that be
what you're actually thinking of I can
think of a couple of pretty go for it
one of them okay one of them was that
both both Jack's so Jack's mom and my
dad had cancer and were really sick and
we were spending a lot of time dealing
with cancer and the idea of writing fun
pop material just wasn't really speaking
to either of us we were having trouble
and and we even kind of associated
Pomplamoose with the illness and a lot
of ways it was it got I don't know it
was just that that's probably the
darkest element of it what do you mean I
associated it with the illness I think
because Jack's mom liked Pomplamoose so
much she she loved the band so much and
and then her loss just sort of made it
difficult to I guess appreciate the
success of the band it was also sick for
a long time so I have spent three years
at you know at at her house you know and
there there's also an element of saria's
getting pretty heavy
this is some heavy heavy stuff here but
you know I I don't regret the choice
that I made of being of being there and
being with my family and for three years
everything else kind of stopped you
no buts and I don't regret that I'm I'm
happy that that we did that but I
couldn't there I didn't do much else in
that time period and and and I feel
really guilty about being angry about
that too not to turn this into a therapy
session but like I feel bad that that
frustrates me right you know and so and
all of that then gets wrapped in with
Pomplamoose because it's like I wasn't
able to do pop news I wasn't out able to
come out with videos weekly I had to be
somewhere else and then I start feeling
guilty that that makes me angry and all
of that is wrapped inside pop loose in
it yeah it imploded on itself so that
was like twenty ten eleven and twelve or
twelve thirteen nine ten and eleven
okay I'm certain both of you guys who
are going through that with nine ten so
pretty much right when it was writing
started right when I was getting started
yeah okay and you were both going
through that with a parent that's what
you said right
I yeah my my dad's my dad's own this
happened they were overlapping but a
little bit later and it wasn't quite as
severe as Jack's mom's illness but yeah
we were both we were both struggling
with that and also the Pomplamoose
business had been something that Jack
was primarily running and that I wasn't
really taking the reins for during all
of this
and so that was frustrating as well I
think you feeling like you were you were
trying to you know pull the whole pull
the whole thing and that we hadn't
really divided up roles successfully
yeah and that's something we that took a
bit of time to figure out and now it's a
little better but we still have
different like I'm I'm a total
workaholic and and I just work like all
the time and and Natalie like loves
quality of life right and and at
five likes to relax and and cook dinner
and watch a TV show and write and like
and that's something I really need to do
and and we do it's it's just it makes it
does make the dynamic interesting and
tough you know and and like that's
something that we talk about all the
time is like is is our because I think
well kind of what I do is almost like a
healthy you know but but at the same
time I feel you know like we like we got
it I don't know yeah I bet I feel like
we've we've somehow managed to find some
sort of a balance it's good now it's
like it works well no it's gotten so
much better but it took several years of
us figuring out our relationship and
sort of actually rebuilding our
relationship after Jack's mom passed and
and like oh you know before we could
actually have a successful business on
top of the relationship we had to have a
strong relationship and now I feel like
that now we're there pomplamoose can
take off again and do you feel that do
you feel now that you know moving
forward or now that you your musical
careers are mortified by Papa moose and
they are your individual careers
separately for sure
yeah I mean pomplamoose is is that is
the yeah no one knows it's my solo stuff
I mean your solo stuff was taking off
pretty pretty nicely though people
people know me as half of Pomplamoose
they don't yeah but yeah you feel do you
feel a need to for all the reasons that
you said earlier to maintain the solo
career because there that keeps things
healthier there's a separate outlet yeah
it's a different sort of expression yeah
I think that there's probably a good
chance that that Pomplamoose will always
you know sort of take take breaks it's
just it's healthy to have other outlets
of expression and to not always be
working together
right now we're in a phase where we're
really excited to be working together
and but you know after putting out an
album and going on two or three times we
might be ready to just sort of like go
back to our separate studios and have
dinner together but like not be working
so closely together everyday and yeah we
both kind of understand that and feel it
out and um I think it was fortunate that
for for the two years when we weren't
working on pomplamoose that we we were
both good with focusing on our solo
careers then it's never it's never like
oh I really want to and the other person
is like now in sync in that way yeah
yeah so that's that's good so it sounds
like this is the year of Coppola moose
again yeah and are you are you talking
about it that way on your channel yeah
yeah we're like um oh yeah yeah yeah
like we're calling the whole thing
season 2 it's like that was season 1 yep
everything's all done and now season 2
so what do we what can we look forward
to what's the what's the plan what's in
the wings obviously more current covers
but also we've recorded several
originals okay so so that'll be a
combination of guilt right okay so what
tension and release yes I like that
analogy so how many originals do you
have I think you already told us he had
like six or so and then we've also got
some some oldie covers that we're kind
of stoked about like five or six older
covers and then we'll be releasing
recording and releasing timely we call
them timely covers chart-toppers yes as
we go on and promote the album and then
a tour in the fall and then probably a
European tour after that and then
possibly another US tour after that so
that the first portion of the year up
till fall is going to be about releasing
new material new videos and then after
that it's going to be about playing live
for the rest of these for the rest of
the
now have you ever when you were touring
before did you guys plan this much ahead
of time like a year like this is here so
this is the most significant sort of
strategy that you've ever implemented
yeah yeah we figured a lot of stuff out
I feel like it's so it's so weird to
look back and think about how little we
understood when we when when Fame just
sort of landed in our laps
we were not expecting it yeah it's a
particular type of yeah thing yeah yes
yeah next thing you know you're in a car
commercial what car commercial was it
Hyundai we did Toyota but we weren't
acting in the Toyota no loyalty so you
did a song or was it a cover that you
guys did or were they originals they all
covers in both commercials Toyota was
mr. Sandman Hyundai was all Christmas
songs yeah when was Christmas themed
right yeah yeah three hundo
and so and how was that for the the
artists within because you know it
doesn't mean you know doing a commercial
we really don't feel that bad about
commercials I actually have a thing
about like I think a lot of people
pegged me for for a hipster and like I'm
I know corporations like I'm like not
about that at all I'm total I think
brand integrations are like one of the
best ways for artists to make money I'd
so much rather have a brand pay me to
write a song than a record label because
the brand isn't gonna tell me what BPM
is to write the song at right they're
not gonna get and say we don't like that
lyric the brands like okay and then they
put it out yeah like they're not dipping
their toes in my creative pot whereas
the label is when a brand gives you
money you don't have to pay it back to
this that's right yeah it's not
indentured servitude yeah Brant I'm just
glad to hear that you're not you don't
feel bad about that - oh yeah but you're
focusing your go
really [ __ ] I got a magnifying glass
trust me we've sold out many times over
I actually I love I have a video from
2009 that I posted it's a vlog where I'm
like not it's not like begging but I'm
basically like saying brands like like
there's all these creative people making
videos like use us like pay us to make
cool stuff and do thoughtful
integrations like you know if you
whatever like the wine thing with Hanan
and you know my drunk kitchen like
that's a beautiful integration it makes
sense
it's native it's it's just awesome and
like that's a great way for the it's a
win for the wine company it's a win for
my drunk kitchen it's just awesome and
and I was trying to explain this in the
video and now it's like I feel like it's
brands are really doing this like
there's so many integrations now and
there and a lot of them are natural some
are as natural but I'm so thrilled about
that it's so much better than signing a
crummy contract and giving away your
your you know future revenue for 10
years and the thing about Hyundai
especially was that when they came to us
first of all I got an email I thought it
was a joke I opened up the email and it
was probably two lines and said hey
writing you on behalf of Hyundai like
your videos was wondering if you guys
ever thought of being on television
being on television on television and it
was for real it was for real sure what
are the details here's my lawyer you
know and they go back crazy person and
and they wanted us to make music they
wanted us to cover public domain songs
which we would then own we own those
songs so we get to sell them and you
know put them on an EP which we did and
we did an entire album we didn't sell
them we gave them away and raised about
a hundred and thirty thousand dollars
for in charity or after the after the
Hyundai campaign for four books so
different school district yeah
and but so so we got to make the music
we got to film the videos at home with a
very very little intervention from them
in terms of them even being in the room
they gave us nice cameras but then they
just sort of backed out and then I got
to edit the commercials just like I edit
all of our video songs and so really
just felt like making three very short
Pomplamoose videos and that they were
gonna buy the airtime for ya is like hey
can we put my videos on television yes
yes
sometimes it all works out beautiful it
was awesome
yeah I wish we got more stuff like that
yeah okay
so last question from me at least I
don't know how many questions you have
if you could have anyone cover your song
an original song and feel guilty about
it who would it be anyone Tom Waits hmm
really
yeah drop that voice on it yeah
yeah Tom Waits Tom Waits if it if I'm
gonna get into Tom Waits what album
should I buy first cuz I'm still an
album guy rain dogs
rain rain dogs do GS dogs yeah two words
two words rain dogs
Wow he's he sounds like an 85 year old
hermit and he's 32 you know but the
smart thing about singing like that is
you always sound good no matter how old
you get when you start singing like
right yeah we saw Kris Kristofferson
with Merle Haggard at the Greek and
Merle didn't hold up as well as
Christmas table person cuz Chris was
kind of always that Sunday morning
coming down kind of place yeah so it's
pretty works it was pretty great it's a
good strategy what about you Natalie if
anyone were to cover one of our songs
cash and feel guilty about it I do it
who should it be I'd hope for I would
honestly I'd be happy if someone like
like Beyonce covered our songs that's
what is grip
yeah which song huh which song I don't
know single ladies that was a really
good I think she's done it's a great
video would never work in the genre of
R&B alright well this is uh it's been
fabulous and great we would ask you to
sign the we actually get people to sign
the table but since this is a hotel room
table I mean you could our credit card
is going to be held responsible I have
to say this is a very weird thing I feel
like you guys know so much about us
really and and yeah it's usually now
dimly lit so it doesn't feel as weird
okay I feel like our sole interview us
no we don't know you guys well we'll be
on your podcast yeah yeah next episode
you have a psyche assed will be your
first guys and there it was our hotel
based conversation with Pomplamoose
could you feel the relationship
blossoming with them over the course of
the conversation
you mean the cop their relationship with
each other their romantic relationship
no their relationship with rhettandlink
I feel like we were we really became
friends you know having never had a
conversation except for that one that
was recorded for the ear biscuit family
they connected well with me but let me
know and all I got to do is connect well
with one of us and then the other one
get the other one gets in automatically
I'm just kidding I thought they liked me
I think they made equal eye contact with
you
so I mean you know and I think maybe our
relationship who knows well you know I
will say and I love it when this happens
and it happens on a pretty regular basis
and it just reminds me that why I love
doing this show
and that is after we got through that
conversation Jack and Natalie said you
know what we didn't know we were gonna
end up talking about some of that stuff
you know even the stuff with their
parents cancer and they had they hadn't
really you know it's not that it's not
public but they hadn't talked about it
in that way before in a setting like
this yeah I'm glad they felt comfortable
talking to us because we're such good
for yes yeah yeah and so you know maybe
you know maybe the next time I go into
the DJ voice I will be introducing some
sort of collaborative musical thing yet
haven't you I mean we're such good
friends we could write a song about
friendships we could write a song about
two guys who are friends who were
friends with a couple who sing together
yeah
it's a great relationship that we're in
with a couple relationship my
relationship with a couple I I think
that that is probably a book third and
fourth wheel but I bringing up the rear
yeah I think we should probably not try
to write songs just in the moment on ear
biscuits I think we should think about
things before we try to do that again
but I unabashedly on the fact that ear
biscuits is our ploy to befriend even
more people who are we who are
interesting on the Internet and
hopefully you feel like you are forging
a friendship along with us that you're
sitting at the table with us or in the
hotel room if we happen to be filming
from somewhere Elser let us know what
you thought about this ear biscuit a
great way to do that it helps us out a
lot is if you leave a review on iTunes
if you leave a comment on SoundCloud
that helps us out a lot continues to
send those are the ear biscuits up and
where other people can discover it
another thing you could do to help
people discover it is just tweet the
link that we share we always share a
link over on our tumblr page which also
goes to our Twitter and our Facebook and
you can just use the hashtag ear
biscuits and share that with your
friends so everyone could enjoy the
biscuits yeah thanks thanks for your
help there also tweet at poplu moose
pump la moose how your spellings pop
blah moose let him know what you thought
that she appreciated the friendship
ization
yeah and if you want to say that you
know rhettandlink are really big fans
they're probably gonna listen to this
but you know you can remind them on
Twitter and you can talk about we need
to musically collaborate to guys the
friend in a couple we're in a Quadra
ship with Tom for a move first of all we
should probably consult our wives before
we start a consequence to their Quadra
ship we got in similes you know what we
should just go maybe we should do a
triple date I think that's what it
should be that would make it a lot less
awkward why are we not have why we
thought about that until right now just
triple date with our wives or Papa moves
could keep our kids and we could just go
on a double date No or we could each
just date our wives
separately but I get my wife right yep
you can help your wife I'll have my wife
Jack and Natalie we'll keep our children
and then they'll write a song for us and
then when we get back we'll record it
our kids this is a good relationship
with Papa and blues we should just break
up on a date where that wives
I like the this sort of the lounge
singer directionless vibe that the song
that we know that we're gonna co-write
with Papa Luis is taking off since none
of the music sounds like that but we're
gonna be a Vegas act with them this
sounds good okay all right thanks for
ear biscuiting with us here you next
week
[Music]
[Music]